this episode of the gist is brought to
you by castlevania lords of shadow 2 it
is much the third and while I don't
normally tell you the date here and
prefer to do it on games but news today
is pretty important because it's my
birthday that does mean I've had 23
years of mulling over what makes a
perfect present so if you want to find
something awesome for the special gamer
in your life I've got five suggestions
some are a bit more sensible than others
as with any video cleverly designed as a
personal present wish list I kind of had
a hard time deciding so let's call this
first one general weaponry first up is a
super realistic looking fictional gun
that you can give to your kids honestly
though this mass effect inspired nerf
gun is way better than a replica because
you can actually shoot people with it
probably not injure but shoot certainly
also the materials listed come down to
gun paint and imagination so there's
that we all know the zombie apocalypse
is an unfortunate inevitability and if
you don't want to be the silly sod who
gets killed off in the first act then
you're going to have to be prepared said
preparation comes in the form of this
epic zombie apocalypse survival kit
complete with a canvas case three knives
two machetes and a high performance camp
act to garba have also set you up with a
bear grylls survival series parang
because if you could choose to be
anybody in the zombie apocalypse it
should definitely be bear grylls as for
presents that I can put to use a little
more immediately everybody loves clocks
and everybody loves Tetris luckily for
us somebody put those two together this
alarm clock looks pretty normal until
the time changes and it devolves into a
mini Tetris game thankfully watching the
minutes roll by is fun again
as for presents of pull my nostalgic
heartstrings oh my god tamagotchis are a
thing again huge for nineties kids these
little bastards swallowed hours of
enjoyment as we tried to keep a
smattering of pixels alive by feeding
them and playing with them if I remember
correctly you also had to clean up its
crap every day but since none of us had
children or any other responsibilities
apart from third grade it was pretty
awesome to have our own fictional pets
honestly if you really want to treat
somebody and happen to have a lot of
cash handy then it's really hard to go
past the 3ds with a link between worlds
attached I was an auntie handheld gamer
not so long ago before I was given this
thing for Christmas and yes it's a
little gold after 3d s is fast becoming
a brilliant system with a lot of awesome
games it's been out long enough that you
aren't paying an absolute fortune and it
has better software than the ps4 or Xbox
one right now not to mention that if you
pick yourself up the zelda bundle you'll
be getting arguably one of the best
games to ever land on the console now
that that's done we'll get onto the less
sensible and my absolute favorite where
my brother and I first played ocarina of
time as kids all I wanted was an ocarina
and we finally got one although I never
learned to play anything on it other
than mary had a little lamb I really
really want this one game item replicas
and action figures are an obvious go to
but this $65 ocarina not only looks just
like the ocarina of time it actually
plays too now it's not just linked who
can throw away sorry as well love shitty
ocarina you can too it's ceramic has 12
holes and unfortunately doesn't come in
polygon form but we make do with what we
have let me know if you liked any of
these and what awesome game a gift you'd
want for your birthday I'll be back next
week when it's not my birthday and I
promise I'll stop talking about my
birthday I'll see you again soon